you
oh boy
hula is the language of the heart and
therefore the heartbeat of the Hawaiian
people and we tell our dancers
everything needs steps your hair your
toenail your eyelashes it needs to dance
now you only whoever he Hey
within three days the competition
tickets are sold out those tickets are
like cold they only bring the best of
the best and so we're very honored to be
able to participate the most prestigious
part of Merrie Monarch is the miserable
hula competition which is the women's
solo competition twelve hollows are
allowed to choose their very best answer
our contestant this year is Kaylee
Khalil any car data you can you Lenny is
a professional hula dancer and we chose
her for many different reasons we wanted
to pretty cool not just a dancer but as
a person European European II had no
kapahala naoki up you Danny Kohana
one of my favorite parts about Merrie
Monarch week is that we go to killer
whale to pay respects to Pele with a
fire goddess the goddess of creation
and it really puts into perspective
where you are in this world and in this
hula journey I've wanted to be in Merrie
Monarch since I was a little kid there
was a lot of times where I thought I
would never it would never happen for me
but pretty much most of my hula journey
has been working towards this moment
which is tomorrow professionally I've
been doing it since 2009 there's a
difference between dancing hula and
Hollow and then singular professional
dancing for the Taurus is like American
Chinese and not the authentic Chinese
food and hotels here's what you'll see
beautiful men and women brightly colored
hair pieces and leis which are all
plastic but you won't see the skill you
want see the love that you would at the
Merrie Monarch festival for Merrie
Monarch we practice every day for I
would say three to four months they're
intense can we try to end one more time
what you doing waiting invitation you
need one invitation come on you guys get
your head game on the biggest
misconception about hula is that it's
easy all the dancers
and you quote me on this have bad knees
all of them so when you see a beautiful
hula dancer
that's gliding the frost stage she's
hurting she's hurting really bad
because nobody walks around with bent
knees you know six inches off the ground
blisters you get blisters on your feet
every single part of your body needs to
work you should be gasping for air but
you can you need to look exactly the
same as when you first started if you
can bend your knees and swing your hips
and have this upper body carriage that's
really operate but make it look
effortless
that's a children Asian ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this allahu la
competición kingly put your money
Paul if I gave the performance of a
lifetime if I gave everything I had to
that one performance those 14 minutes up
there just me I've already won
ha
you're just a vessel for all of these
people that came before you for all the
knowledge that you have and it's your
responsibility to share that it's your
responsibility to perpetuate but it
would be so nice to hear my name being
called
I know ladies are doing this alone hula
for 2016 Kaylee
you know I don't dance hula just to be a
miss Lola I do it because I just because
I love it and I can explain to you why I
do I think I think it's something you
just burn well in modern life can we be
accepted by others in all of our facets
the beautiful and the ugly the
comfortable and the uncomfortable how do
we open that Pandora's box and dance
with it my name is Evangeline and I am
put two artists
butoh is an art form that was born in
Japan in the 1950s now it is a global
art form for me Bhutto is the dance of
darkness the dance of the subconscious I
think that body and mind and spirit are
completely connected when we access the
body through repetition there is a part
of the mind that surrenders and we begin
to access emotions
there is no Homo erectus anymore
brutal training is really really really
challenging to be pushed to the limit to
that extent and encouraged to have an
encounter with yourself is not an easy
endeavor but it's a particularly acute
challenge for people who are
incarcerated
I started that may work in correctional
facilities with bruto in 2006 yeah
the classes at Edgecombe are very
powerful they're also a process and in
the correctional facilities it's a very
volatile environment my agenda is to
start with a blank slate it's not my
place to judge them it's my place to
provide a space of self acceptance for
them but please for rehabilitation
once they connect to the sense of
empowerment that's a very important
concept for people who are incarcerated
self-knowledge self power how can I be
in control of my of my body that is
essentially being controlled by the
states the ones that keep coming back
and repeat and believe in the repetition
and start on a path of commitment
achieve great results it's a dance from
the guts to dance from the soul it's
magic
you
country music and grabbing your partner
for a dose IDO you probably have a fuzzy
memory of trying to master these moves
in middle school gym class am i right so
why were we all forced a couple up and
endure this embarrassment well it's all
thanks to Henry Ford now grab your
partner and Osito he was the father of
the car and the assembly line but here's
a little-known fact Henry Ford loved to
dance especially with his wife Clara
square dancing has deep roots in
American culture dating back to colonial
times it remained popular until the
Walton polka went mainstream in the 19th
century so in the 1920s for took it upon
himself to revive the old tradition
let's do it y'all he opened a Ballroom
in his hometown and encouraged his
factory workers and their families to
take part
he felt square dancing helped teach
manners exercise values and grace soon
after he worked to create a national
square dancing program Boards of
Education across the country started
endorsing Ford's mission and since then
students have been taught to square
dance today 24 states still love square
dancing as their official state dance so
if you feel like reliving awkward gym
class moments I'm sure you can find
square dancing lessons somewhere nearby
I'll jump up and never come down swing
you a pretty girl round and round
you
anything that you do definitely has an
element of power when you're actually
out there and yes you go down or you're
actually walking and the beat is taking
you then you just go for it
my name is Keith Holt when I'm out at
the balls I become keep Avenue at the
Crown Prince of Baltimore
voguing it's an underground art form
that was brought to like throw shade on
the dance floor ballroom in general was
developed to be underground partially
because of so much stigma and hate that
the LGBTQ community have Asperger's this
is a place that you can be anything you
want today James is like that new
generation Lucas how you doing I'm the
legendary little James Caan I'm the
Volcom extraordinaire he is like the
Beyonce of the water I'm saying look who
is my best friend I am the voice of
Baltimore look mizrahi the dramatic one
he commentates people James mug and
myself are something that are really
leading the next generation I work for
the Baltimore City Health Department I'm
the youth outreach coordinator with that
I've got to come up with a different
event and something that kept coming up
was one adorable so we have our free
ball because Baltimore has a high rate
and HIV that's why we make sure that
every even that we have we do offer both
HIV testing and HIV linkage to treatment
as well for me it's really like this is
not just a job this is my community
these are people that I know for them is
not just extracurricular activity
anymore it's actually a part of my life
you